(chilling music)
- Where the fuck are they, come on.
(whispers) Fuck.
(phone buzzes)
- Easy, brother, we're good.
- Yo,
that's them, cuz.
- [Nervous Man] (whispers) Fuck, oh fuck.
- Tell me when.
- Okay, let's do it.
- [Man In Passenger Seat] Go, go, go.
(gun clicks)
(tires screech)
(men yelling)
- Get down! Get those things down!
- Stay down, stay down!
- Get your fuckin' hands up!
Get your hands up! Get down!
Lay down- fucking lay down!
Don't fuckin' move!
Get down, get down!
Like a fuckin' dog! Splay out!
Oi! Get back!
- Don't shoot.
Oi! Get back! Get back!
Get back, I'll blow your fuckin' head off!
- What's up? (laughing) Yeah?
Daily offender.
Crazy standoff.
- Get in the car, man.
Stop fuckin' around.
- Go! Go!
(tires screeching)
- [Man In Handcuffs] Woohoo!
(yelling)